i'm going first because i'm not gonna
hold this one in the event we run out of
time yeah cool
watching the browns ravens game last
night i thought of you
on one specific play it's it's the the
failure in whiteboard play design oh
here we go we've talked
we've talked about it in the past as it
relates to the bright idea that
offensive coordinators have
to put the circle that is a tight end
blocking a defensive end and we know how
that plays out when it's time for the
circle and the
x to hit right the browns came up with
a similar gaff in their design of a fake
punt
and i don't know if you saw the fake
punt play out in real time
but the way it was drawn up it was going
to work right
the circle was andrew sandejo who isn't
a blocker by trade he's a safety
yes the x was linebacker lj forte who is
a guy who sheds blocks for a living
right and who is 20 pounds heavier than
andrew sandejo right
and the fake punt would have worked if
the circle
had neutralized the x the problem is the
circle approached the
x and the x threw the circle onto his
ass
and then tackled the punter and ripped
the ball out in the process
so again what it looks like on the
whiteboard
and what's going to happen when it's
time to go out and put
one guy against another when there may
be a disparity in one guy's ability to
block and the other guy's ability to
tackle
that's when your bright ideas are going
to fall apart no doubt about it
i mean you we we laugh about this every
week right oh yeah hey
there's you know there's the pass
catching tight end blocking the best
pass rusher in football
it was good why do they keep doing it i
don't keep doing it
you don't see it in new england that's
what i'll tell you once again
new england finds a way to get their
alignment on linemen every time it
drives me crazy
but what the hell happened to you what
who are you
have you been like smoking my daddy's
cigars what the hell is going on with
you
johnny film session johnny film session
breaking it down you're you're the new
you're the new ron look all you need is
time
and that's one thing i've learned this
year since i'm staying home for the
foreseeable future on sundays
i've picked up 14 hours of travel time
and it's really not the easiest thing to
do to watch back games on the weekend
yeah or on monday when you're exhausted
right so i've had
time to watch multiple games and i
intend to watch multiple more and it
gives you
if you just can you know that's that's
what i don't like about sundays yeah
there's too much going on you can't
focus it drives me crazy i want to focus
on one thing
right like my grievance and now you get
to focus on your yeah well yeah you get
to you get to focus on the game you get
to really feel how the game played out
and you'll have a better understanding
of the game i
i totally get that and i feel cheated as
a human being like if you're going to
watch film and all that i need to start
reading cba agreements and doing lawyer
crap
i gotta start upping my game all right
my grievance is gonna be with
two running quarterbacks from this past
weekend that um
you know that i love both of them my boy
blue josh allen and buffalo
and lamar jackson in baltimore i mean
these are two of the most talented
quarterbacks in football but my issue is
here they are in games where they were
blowing the other team out in the fourth
quarter and
both of them were still being asked by
their team
on design quarterback runs let alone i
would question maybe why they were even
in the game
and then both of them i would say within
those runs
we're being too reckless and careless
themselves and i'm just saying this it's
a grievance because i like watching you
play lamar and josh allen and i like
baltimore and buffalo
like what the hell are we doing protect
themselves from themselves
players are meatheads they're football
players
they can't protect themselves as mike
talks about all the time
and they'd get caught up in the emotions
especially young players and lamar and
josh are still except for kylie murray
yeah
yeah he's the only one we've seen really
they're still young but i just had an
issue with them
and what they were being asked to do
that late in the game with the scenario
of the game and everything about it i
just thought it was very risky on both
teams parts
when i talked to john harbaugh after the
ravens win i asked him about the big hit
that he took
that lamar jackson took and he said we
actually talked
a drive earlier about taking him out and
you know it's a tough balance he wants
to play
yeah and basically harbaugh's bottom
line is i hope to have that problem
every week where i'm trying to decide
when to remove my starting quarterback
from a game that is easily in hand hi
i'm mike tarico and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports